my name is Stephanie Hicks I am a
faculty member at Johns Hopkins actually
a little bit about me I've loved that
everybody started with the about me
sighs it's very helpful so I am effects
member at Johns Hopkins in the bio stats
department similar to Roger pang I have
a couple interest one is data science
education so if you have any interest in
talking about that I would love to talk
to you about that that's not what I'm
going to talk about today but I have a
lot of opinions about that what I am
going to talk about today is
specifically a little bit about what I
do for my research so my research is in
the analysis of genomic data
who knows what genomic data is okay
that's a great number of you awesome
so if you do work with genomic data you
may or may not have heard of the
software project called bioconductor I'm
going to explain a little bit about what
that is it's kind of like the cousin or
sister project to crayons for
specifically for the analysis of genomic
data and a few other fun facts about
myself I recently founded the our ladies
Baltimore chapter as of May 2018 so we
are on our third event next week but I
loved getting to meet so many our ladies
here in the local DC area and then I'm
also creating a children's book for
women statisticians and data scientists
so as you know I have as Jared mentioned
they have young kids and I went on a
mission to try and find children's books
featuring statisticians data science and
it's weren't really any there were some
specifically for stem but I'm a mission
to make that happen first a decision to
do so I'm going to give you a little bit
of a taste of that at the end of the
talk
all right another thing about myself is
Jared mentioned I have two young kids
Theo is my youngest happy birthday Theo
he was born a year yesterday and alex is
my oldest
so he's two-and-a-half and if you look
at this picture long enough you'll
quickly realize two things one this was
taken very recently it was the day we
voted earlier this week so he's got his
future voter sticker on and then too
you'll see that he's got
minions on his shirt or as he likes to
call them aliens and so when I was
preparing my talk at the lab sure is all
of us did I decided to go with the
minion theme so crayon so as most of us
are here for an hour south conference we
all know what cran is it's a great
software project that's got over 10,000
our packages to the state and it does
basic things such as data wrangling or
creating plot but then it also can do
more advanced things such as web
scraping or analysis of financial time
series data or analysis of clinical
trial data and so forth we all love cram
so if we look at the subset of people
that are in this room for example half
of us are on our phone either tweeting
or looking at cool links or learning
about new packages you might be Elsa be
on Twitter and so you might be tweeting
about these hashtags our sets DC and our
sets and our ladies and you can go on
your phone or computer to the our
project org website and if you go there
there's something called there's a link
called other projects is this work yeah
there's a link called other projects and
if you go there you'll see a few things
there's this thing called community
services area which is wonderful and
then right below it is something called
special areas of application so under
the first item under the special areas
of application is something called bio
conductor : bioinformatics with our so
it has a list of broad goals the broad
goals are to provide access to a wide
range of powerful and statistical
graphical methods for the analysis of
genomic data facilitating integration of
biological data allowing the rapid
development that's scalable and
interoperable software promoting high
quality reproducer research and creating
training in computational and
statistical methods for the analysis of
genomic data so that gives you a broad
overview of what is bioconductor so for
those of you that have not heard of
bioconductor formal introductions
Coran meet your cool cousin bioconductor
okay more seriously bye
director is an open source and open
development software project meaning
open source anybody can go look at the
code anybody can go use the code open
development meaning anybody can
contribute code at the end in 2001 under
Robert gentleman from Genentech now at
23andme I believe and now it's today I
think it's got over twelve full-time
employees that are funded by the
bioconductor project that work on
developing the core infrastructure in
the maintenance of the packages and
bioconductor has some big priorities I
would argue that those are reproducible
research and high-quality documentation
so for example every software package
and bioconductor comes with a vignette
and that is really helpful when you
don't necessarily want to scroll through
just the reference manual the vignette
is meant to walk you through an example
analysis or to demonstrate actually how
to use the package which is not the same
thing of just looking up a function
inside the reference manual it has a
pretty diverse community support group
so we have an online forum that you can
go ask questions and you can get experts
to respond to your questions we also
have a slack team that you can join and
you can ask those questions in the slack
environment workflows so bioconductor is
really nice because they've developed
these users users have developed and
contributed workflows specific for
different types of genomic analysis so
if you've ever heard of the analysis of
gene expression data or DNA methylation
data or mutations in your genome there
are workflows if you are new to the
field of genomics and you want to figure
out how do I analyze my fancy genomic
data you can just go download a workflow
and follow the steps that they have
demonstrated for you to analyze your own
data and then teaching resources so by a
conductor has spent a lot of time and
effort developing teaching resources
that you can use in the classroom to
teacher students so when you think about
bioconductor image that by your
connector aims for is that when you when
you are analyzing a lot of genomic data
there are a lot of great and unique
packages out there and tools that you
can use to analyze the data with a very
unique similar to a musician a musician
is very you
and bioconductor serves as the conductor
of the set of musicians and an orchestra
to keep things on pace and makes their
shirt everything works together in a
flexible way okay so in the next part of
my talk I'm going to give you a
demonstration of a little bit about by a
conductor like what's in bio conductor
and then a package that I think you'll
find really slow so first is a package
called bio C package tools and this
contains functions too that assess
metadata around bioconductor packages
and it's in a tidy data format so if you
load in the library packages or library
bio C package tools there's one function
bio C download stats and in one line of
code you can have a table that's loaded
into R with a row containing information
with the name of the package the number
of distinct downloads IPS for a given
month and year and there's this last
column called repo so this is the type
of package it is so you could ask well
how many types of packages are there so
for example because this is a table then
the world of Tidy verse is open up to
you so you can apply anything you want
in the tidy verse here so for example
you can use the filter function to
select the rows from 2018 select just
the package and repo column ask for the
number of distinct rows group by repo
whatever that is and then summarize by
the total number of packages and you'll
quickly see that bioconductor has three
main types of packages one software
similar to the software that's available
in crayon and then two we have these
things called annotation packages and
experiment experiment data packages if
you've ever done any type of analysis
and genomic data you'll realize there's
a lot of bookkeeping that has to be done
so for example if you want to look at
genes that are expressed in the human
genome you have to ask what hewmet
reference human genome it is for example
every six months to a year the reference
genome changes so like the position
where you would expect a gene to be in
one reference genome may be slightly
different than the
shouldn't you expected indifference
Renji a different reference genome so
there's a lot of bookkeeping and the
annotation packages basically
streamlines that process and makes your
life much easier the experimental data
packages they contain essentially
process data that is great for teaching
because the data is just kind of ready
there for you to go yeah you could also
ask so crayon as I mentioned has over
10,000 packages
currently available bioconductor has
around 1700 but it's been steadily
increasing so inside of the bias e
package tools function it only loads in
data from I think 2009 I'm not sure why
there's no data before that I know
there's data somewhere but it's not in
that function but starting in 2009 it
looks like they're around 400 or 500
packages and we've been steadily
increasing through 2018 and this is just
software packages so we have a really
big diverse community of packages okay
so what is the standard object when I
talk about genomic data how does our
think about that so there's this thing
called genomic ranges and I would argue
that that's one of the the most standard
objects that bioconductor uses genomics
ranges is essentially a data frame a
constrained data frame so you can appear
there's a chromosome so this is not a
piece of data this is like and you can
imagine a chromosome in our body
chromosome one and then inside of this
region right here this is a genomic
location in that chromosome and so when
you translate that to our or when you
translate that to something on the
computer we want to record for example
in that one specific genomic region we
want to record a few things one we want
to know what's the chromosome number so
in this case it's chromosome one
- what's the start of that genomic
location so how many bases in starting
from one two three four or five all the
way down does my genomic region start
and does my genomic region end in the
world of genomics there's positive
strands and negative strands I'm not
going to go into that but it's again
bookkeeping essentially and then there's
this thing
there's a dotted line here and
everything to the dotted line is
considered metadata that can be whatever
you want so on the left side of the
table that is a constrained data frame a
G ranges object expects those four
columns every single time you create a G
ranges object on the right side you can
put whatever you want there so if you
think about this in the world of the
tiny verse this is actually already a
tiny data frame because each row is one
observation namely a specific genomic
region and then every column is a
specific variable so I'm gonna explain
why that's useful in a minute so how do
you create a genomic ranges object it's
really easy there's a package called
genomic ranges and there's a function
called G R ranges so you can create a
genomic ranges object by providing those
four column names that it was looking
for so seek names contains information
about the chromosome location strand
contains information about the positive
or negative chromosomes
direction of the chromosome and then
there's this thing called ranges ranges
are essentially a simplified version of
G ranges it doesn't care and for it
doesn't have information about the
chromosome name it just contains
information about the start and the end
of the genomic region so thinking back
to this figure that I was showing you
before it was starting at this position
for these two genomic regions and ending
at this base position and then we had
these two pieces of metadata gene ID or
the gene name you can think about it
like that
and score score it a super generic but
you can just think about it as something
that you've measured about that genomic
region so in a really quick way we've
now loaded up a standard infrastructure
I'd argue the standard infrastructure
that bioconductor uses to build almost
all of its packages when you're talking
about genomic data ok so what can you do
with that I mean that's great but what
can you do with that so for example it's
common to ask what's the width of that
genomic region how long or why does that
genomic region so for example you are
literally subtracting the end value from
the beginning value and you can get the
width of that for those two genomic
regions you can also do things
to select or filter for a set of rows
this is base our notation so gr which is
the new genomic ranges öppet object open
bracket this is a classic base our way
to filter a set of two filter set of
rows looking for all the genomic ranges
that have a score greater than 15 and so
similar to the reasons that the tidy
verse and deep play are was invented
that's not super human readable and so
there has been recent efforts to try and
make the analysis of genomic data more
human readable specifically with what
I've discovered recently called the
apply ranges package so if you're
interested in getting into the analysis
of genomic data I would suggest checking
it out because I've incorporated into my
workflow and it's been wonderful and the
whole goal was to just make the genomic
data analysis more human readable so
this is not my work this is the
brainchild student Stuart Lee from
Monash University die cook and Michael
Lawrence he's one of the key works at
Genentech but he's one of the main core
by a core bioconductor developers it's
the idea for this is to define an API
meaning literally extends the DPI our
package that map's relational genomic
algebra to verbs similar to the way deep
layer does but act on this tidy genomic
data another great idea to just
straight-up borrowed apply our syntax
and design principles and another great
idea compose verbs together with a pipe
operator from a critter that would make
this process of analysis of genomic data
much more human readable so for example
you can load in the ply ranges object
and instead of doing the base our way to
selecting a set of rows you can take the
G ranges object now pipe it into the
filter function so for those of you
familiar with the DPR package you'll
recognize the filter function so you
were filtering for the genomic regions
that have a score of greater than 15 so
we had one genomic region that met that
criteria you can pipe that genomic
ranges object that's now filtered and
to the function called width and asked
for the width of that genomic region and
so forth so we're really taking the
analysis of genomic data or the the
packages that have been developed on the
G ranges object and making them much
more human readable there is a whole set
of verbs that have been developed for
the pie ranges package for example some
of these you'll recognize the ones in
bold where literally the origin of them
came from the D PI R package so you'll
recognize summarize mutate select range
group by and filter and then the ones
that are not in bold are very similar
they're just some unique things to
genomic data that make the analysis more
fun as I would like to say and so they
are doing very similar things like for
example there's a whole set of joins and
unions there is a set of filter by
overlaps filter by non overlaps and so
forth so for example if I were
interested in joining two genomic ranges
objects for example if I in the figure a
I have a genomic ranges object X and a
genomic ranges object Y depicted by the
pink bars so if I wanted to join those
two genomic ranges objects there are a
couple ways I could think about doing
that I could join them by taking the
overlap of the intersection or of the
inner part of the genomic ranges object
or the genomic regions or the intersect
or the left they're just a lot of
different things that are unique to
genomic data and then because everything
is in a tidy framework again the world
of the tidy verse is open to you so for
example you can make fantastic juji
plots and so forth and that's it so this
is my hat tip to Gaby
so she's the founder of the global
organization called our ladies and I
mentioned that I'm creating a children's
book so I'm working with a sketch artist
who works at Hopkins and she's been
doing a fantastic job so if anybody's
interested in getting involved in this
project I would love your help I can
tell you all about it and thank you for
your time
you
[Applause]